hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is one of Germany's most
distinguished and most popular authors
of children's books and here he is in
person Palma very much for joining us
today here on talking Germany wonderful
to have you here great stuff now in over
40 years as an author Palmer has written
well over 40 box and he's very very
versatile penning short stories novels
plays and even a libretto for a
children's opera he also illustrates his
own books and sometimes those of others
now one more thing I should tell you
before we get going is this his most
famous creation known as the zams the
sams sa ms is a curious creature with
red hair a pig's nose and blue freckles
Palma I've just described the zams you
have sold four million copies of the
sams book tell us a little bit more
about the character of the sams yeah
that's amazi ganglia and phangan well
I'll have to begin with the father of
the sams in my in my neck in tied Garbus
when I was a child there was an
accountant who worked for my father in
his small business he was a very
conventional and very shy person very
shy but at the same time very friendly
kid as a child I became very good
friends with him and he did a lot to
encourage my drawing skills but I also
often watched how he behaved when my
father treated him unjustly I could
never understand why never said no past
that's not true we always remain silent
when he thought the vin how old were you
at the time when you were bi I was 12
years old at the time I thought wow if I
could only make him a bit happier but
you can't do that when you're a child
when you grow up and are a writer
however you can take that figure and
bring it to life I described him exactly
the way he was in my story he works in
an office too I thought now
do something to make you happy first of
all I described as normal life how
miserable it was then I invented this
fantastic creature that arrives on a
Saturday samstag in German it's the
walking dog Sam strike today samster
yeah yeah yeahs in dutch the creature is
called zetas from SATA doc so the zoms
comes on a Saturday and it's the
complete opposite of him who know the
way it works is that when he's shy it
becomes cheeky quinta when he's unable
to make contact with or talk to anyone
it starts chatting to everyone yeah
actually he's moving moody so when he's
afraid it has to be brave the zoms comes
from a fantasy world it has a face full
of blue spots like freckles he notices
almost too late that whenever he
expresses a wish a spot disappears from
its face and the wishes fulfilled of
course he doesn't know this so he says
things all day like I wish you'd sit
down or I wish you'd be quiet or I wish
you wouldn't bother me he wishes and
wishes and finally realizes that the
zoms has almost run out of blue spots
from fossil food very interesting the
the sense i get is that what you can do
with writing is that you can take
something that really happened and you
can rewrite it you can write a new
version of it good norm and convey
exactly exactly you could say that i
gave life to a character that already
existed of course this is literature and
I garnished it a little gave it a
certain way of talking that it didn't
have in reality this little of course
you have to invent experiences for the
figure to make things work better so
that it can become a fuller and more
beautiful character or writer don't ruin
built and I mean you're talking about a
figure from your old from your own
childhood just it to what extent has
your of the books that you have written
the children's books that you have
written I don't want to be too much of a
psychologist but to what extent have
they be
mean you re writing your own childhood
yeah about the tomb was examd as he i'd
have to say there that as a child I
never really had any children's books
nor did I read any in a way I'm trying
to work out certain things about my
childhood through my books but I don't
want to make it to specific to
individual so that people think that I'm
just talking about myself childhood
experiences can be an almost endless
source of inspiration command and OC a
few trips it's very interesting that the
sams books I mean that they've sold four
million copies in Germany they have been
free movies made out of them it's
incredibly successful but they the
feeling I have when I read the sun's
books is that they the the atmosphere
they're taking place in is some time a
long long time ago maybe in the 1950s or
something like that it's not today yeah
yes Tim there's SSM spoke with the ocean
that's right I actually wrote the first
sams book in 1960 and it was influenced
by my childhood around 1950s reading
some spooky three top when we shot the
first zoms film where i co-wrote the
script we thought hard about what sort
of an environment it would take place in
should it be a modern city no we called
it poetic realism put a teacher really
smooth mechanic a cannon you can't tell
for sure from the backdrop what period
its said end it was shot in my hometown
BAM back which is a sort of ideal world
because it was untouched by the Second
World War all the old buildings are
still there it could be 19 20 or 1999
see we also designed the interiors so
that you couldn't tell what period it
was one thing this is unrealistic it
seems to be a realistic movie but I
always ask people when they watch it
whether they saw a single car in it we
removed all the cars for shooting making
it a magical town of sorts
I know Fat Albert is that ok
palma let's go right back to your early
early days and let's go back to your
grandfather he was a very very important
person for you got inspiration yeah even
was that same angles father had that I
have to tell you a story my granddad
owned a country gasthaus the sort you
find in franconia know what a month octo
but yeah but he also had a second
profession he was a cooper in other
words he made barrels and he was also a
gifted storyteller his guest house was
always full because people would come
from miles around to hear another one of
his stories another funny tale by hair
mutton high mine that was his name I
always used to love to hear his stories
and started to understand how they were
constructed if we'd been to the village
together during the day I knew what had
gone on but that evening in the
guesthouse I heard his version I'd say
granddad that's not how it was and he'd
say it doesn't matter what's important
is that it's a good story this is a new
go to Keith this I'm gonna see if he
told the tale a week later then he'd add
even more to it and find a good punch
line he was the one who said to me you
can tell a good story to come on tell me
a story and then after I'd practiced a
little and come up with some stories of
my own he gave me a blue notebook that
was no small thing in the postwar years
you couldn't get hold of paper and I'd
started off writing in the margins of
newspapers then he went and bartered a
bottle of schnapps for some riding
equipment in Qatar I plan so I had my
blue notebook and a pen and I'd write my
stories down and read them to him at the
weekend these stories this relationship
with a truly loving grandfather really
had a big influence on me you have to
understand that my father was absent he
was in the Navy somewhere
and France my mother had died and I had
this chubby warm-hearted grandfather
decency a dick my mom had seeking cause
father there was a lot of them both
inside and out and he took me under his
wing and a difficult time and helped me
develop you photodoc because I grew up
in shrine for it in the postwar years in
Enoch it was an industrial town that was
important for the war effort foot so it
had been bombed at least once a week
being widowed schweinfurt Sophia I
remember spending a lot of time sitting
in a raid bunkers does a human love
truth scalar the bombs were falling
outside the building was shaking and the
lights went out it's cancer i was i
could go and see to the thinking this
leaked or something how did that feel
the itch by angst leash and mine father
i was a frightened child my father
remarried and went off to war again and
i had a new mother nakatsu when I saw
her lighting a candle with her fingers
shaking the grown-ups fear spread to me
as a child and each VAR c agudas easton
of this eventually she said she'd had
enough of shrine for it and wanted to go
home see to look she listens I was
injured she left the house locked
everything up and went back to the
countryside daddy can't you see and I
got this grandfather at first I was
still very disturbed at all these tix
used to wind up my hair chew off my
fingernails and things like that but my
grandfather's loving care brought me out
of it nowadays I don't feel like I have
to overcome in a trauma or anything that
was the turning point in my life thus
vada whistles whom I namely even mm-hmm
so that's the power of the personality
of your grandfather it's also the power
of storytelling but just there was
another little episode in there because
I know when your father came back yeah
from being in a prisoner of war
and yeah he looked at you and he could
see you sitting there with a book like
this and writing away and he said that's
the end of that I have no time for that
whatsoever you know I over N hunt vago
guns him he was a handyman in the
traditional sense you're supposed to
work with your hands I'm if he saw me
sitting there reading something easy
well he probably had problems with me
anyway after being away so long and
missing out on a crucial part of my life
all of a sudden this father comes home
and finds a son who's completely
different from him am i part of Uncle
search for my father was a great
sportsman fun he was a rower and loved
to race I'd sit there bent over a book
and read and he'd say have you done your
homework and I'd say yes he'd asked me
if I had nothing else to do and if I
said no he'd send me out to sweep the
yard he made it clear that for him
reading was a waste of time when you
could be doing something useful it's
like mostly in this site fishmen Norman
couldn't live beyond this outside all
right hmm later you became a student and
you had a son of your own you you've got
a couple of kids and you were still a
relatively young man you didn't have
that much money you wanted to read
stories to your son yeah you went to the
library and you weren't happy with the
books that were there and you decided
i'm going to write my own stories
there's my good nose or we have an and
that's exactly how it was we had this
dusty old municipal library where I used
to look for books from my son I'd read
them and realize they were still full of
the spirit of the third high as these
days if kids get together they call it a
gang some tune the kunai nebanda back
then and those books they used a word
thin line it's an expression like a
military unit I didn't want to read
stuff like that to my son
Nick meet bring me Foley's now because
so I decided it would be easier to write
them myself that's how my first
children's book came about with Vanessa
skin noble
I wouldn't I I would genuinely like to
have the job of being the driver yeah of
a rolling library fantastic a library on
wheels it comes to town yeah and it's a
social event is this yeah each point in
my neck contenders I wish there had been
mobile libraries when I was a child it's
a social event that brings all the
children together but there probably
wouldn't be as many children these days
because reading habits are dying out
leave me laugh not as many children read
these days I mean my neck when I was
growing up there wasn't a mobile
librarian there wasn't even a librarian
shine photos that in schweinfurt
Nicholas Givaudan win but that was the
yeah I read somewhere that there were
you your first experiences of reading
were in an American Library yeah I know
this will declare that serious guy I was
about to get a dad in schweinfurt there
was an America house they were trying to
get Germans acquainted with all the
anglo-saxon literature that was
unavailable in the third wife not
support the immune so they set up these
America houses where there'd be speeches
and lectures they had a big library and
a friend told me you could borrow books
there for free course the dog nice all
you needed was a library pass Nixon talk
so I turned up there the next day and
filled my bag with books sadly they
didn't have any children's books so I
got Hemingway and Faulkner and so on I
can tell you one story about Hemingway
by Hemingway's is he often writes two or
three pages of pure dialogue without
even saying Sam said or Sally answered
he just assumes that the reader knows
after the 24th conversation if it's he
or she who is talking oh very sweet obey
the sea as a child that didn't seem
right so I took a pen and wrote in front
of each line who was talking then the
librarian came along and said that if I
did that ever again
she take my library pass away these are
always ways Vic that tells us something
very interesting about mr. MA yeah you
mentioned it it's a problem I think in
Germany in many countries as far as i
can tell certainly in Germany there is
something like a class divided there are
children who grew up in households where
people read books where they read books
or books are read to them and there are
kids who grow up in households where
books aren't red you know have a very
strong opinion about this I know yeah
there's an nco theory illegal smuggling
that's a very difficult problem and I
deeply regret the fact that it is so I'm
always glad to find exceptions I often
give readings in schools and sometimes
the teacher tells me confidentially that
a child's parents don't even have books
at home but that the child has borrowed
say 20 odd books from the school library
16 the book window shooter puberty goes
always could be this is an then you know
that the child likes to read that also
happens but of course children whose
parents encourage them to read because
they read themselves and are from a
different social class those children
have better chances in life because
they've grown up with books mine fuzzy
do you know dmitrichenko's van would
move there has to be a lot more of that
as with us and so I don't just go to
municipal libraries for my readings
where i'll just meet children who
already know my books anyway the my new
burger can order me can i go to
preschool classes or to special schools
for mentally handicapped children oh so
much being true in fact I see it as my
duty to get children like this also
interested in books GABA is oh these I'm
always glad to get feedback from
teachers who write things like just
imagine Mehmet's never borrowed a book
from the library before and after you
had visited he asked about what else
you'd written he couldn't remember your
name but I gave him one of your books
and now he's reading you give one gets
least they are wonderful yeah wonderful
you're not just you don't just write
books films film scripts II you know we
mentioned it short stories poems and
everything you also illustrate the
stories you're a very what an
accomplished illustrator I love power
Mars illustrations and we've got what
we've got here is a is the first of the
Sam series we talked about the sams and
what we've got here hiding behind is a
translation of that book but I'm not
holding it the right way am I you tell
us what we've got here plumber yeah yeah
that's as the sea unhappy troopers hit
song as handsome as my dad yes that's
the arabic translation the first time i
picked it up of course i read it the
wrong way around until i realized it had
to be read from back to front then i
looked at the picture on the cover and
couldn't figure out what was different
my zoms has a nose that's a bit like a
pig snout to get around that I say it's
like an electrical socket but it's not
acceptable to Muslim children to have a
character who has a pig's nose because
the pig is considered unclean einen NASA
had visa and honesty of ein schwein so
the Arabic publisher retouched it and so
my character now has a big nose but the
story is still the same dick an asset
yeah I'm gonna shoot this guy could be
and how many languages of the books been
translated into it was a little over 30
hmm what's interesting as well as that
yeah we heard in the report your you at
least two of your children have already
have all also yeah written children's
stories 9 Canada to know not children's
stories my youngest daughter who also
runs a theatre and puts on lots of
children's place has published 14 books
and my son our eldest son as my wife
always reminds me writes for adults when
the editors own tribe 20 have a fear of
acts in there okay it's a little bit
like in the Middle Ages where there was
there were there was the master who had
a sort of a workshop and fences on there
the craft to the children
if you haven't been to bamberg and you
come to Germany you must go to bamberg
it's a place I really really love palmar
is nodding yeah 70,000 people live in
the city two million tourists each year
that's a lot of tourists yeah Wednesday
I'm some stuffed with one bag yes if you
walk through bamberg on a Saturday then
you have to brace yourself to get
through the crowds of japanese and
italian tourists that fill the town the
gig manam biston gonna the best thing is
to not go into town at all that or just
go to the less touristy places and the
old part where only the locals go you
know where the places are good and your
relationship we've talked a lot about
your childhood be your your relationship
to handbags really started in your
childhood yeah and you had a really I
think it's true to say a really warm
feeling for the city yeah the thing that
meets uzum does the ish Western that's
because my mother sister or rather my
stepmothers sister lived in bamberg and
I always got to go to BAM bag and the
holidays for one week at my aunts I new
vogue through done to santa ana wouldn't
it was a good combination she the Sun
was always shining because it was the
summer holidays and I got ice cream
which I was rarely allowed enshrined
foot I didn't have to go to school so I
could do whatever I wanted so my basic
reaction was that bad bag was paradise
that's how that feeling never went away
and when I heard that there was a house
for sale in the old town of all places
in a small quiet street then I asked my
bank for a loan instant closet it worked
out and we were able to buy the house
which me included Zach Nia's I'm a Hindi
clicked on IM dun da-dun hauschka
coughed and you still live there yeah
you live inside the city center in the
old city center of beautiful bamberg you
don't work there though you work
somewhere else and that's a very
interesting location
Your Honor ish are my work ok Funland Oh
rather let me start again when he can
bump up in BMC if you look for we have a
lot of friends and the phone is always
ringing if I'm working in bamberg or
have just come up with a particularly
nice sentence and start to write it down
then the phone rings or someone drops by
to visit so I have to get away somewhere
to write we found an Orangery out in the
Franconian countryside on the grounds of
a little palace schloss perkins rd
mudding floss floss building food what
is in orangery lingerie this is I know
an Orangery is a room with big windows
where the counts who still live there
put their palms and orange trees for the
winter the pool new Tom there's even a
servant who's responsible for running
the old heater to make sure it's warm
enough inside and you have an ocean
around early yeah me too ok we just
rented it doesn't belong to us the
Spartan it's from the 18th century The
Orangery was very run down and the big
windows had been walled up it was being
used as a stable for horses when we
rented it my wife said why in heaven's
name have you rented a stable but we
renovated it and put back the old
windows and now it's a wonderful bright
room perfect for drawing painting and
writing my own tribe income and there's
a forest nearby I just have to walk a
hundred metres to get to it if I ever
have a little writer's block which does
happen then I go for a ramble in the
woods it takes about an hour or 50
minutes if I hurry when I get back I
usually know what it is that I want to
rise by target
have you ever been to a book party 9 no
I have a lot of playing cards from Ivan
books but I've never been there but I
can Berg is the capital of Scott yeah do
you play Scott name my game is popular
in southern Germany and above all
Bavaria it's called chef cough cough
cough cough person shaft cop sheepshead
yeah is that is that related to doping
cough your head yeah yes it's similar at
the moment I play more double cops than
shaft cough cough cough is played with
one deck topic up foot too everything's
double hence double cops mmm quote I see
my problem I've been in Germany a long
time is that when people are playing
these games Scott or double cough cough
or any of these games is that I sit
there and I sort of watched them playing
and I have the feeling it's quite
complicated mm under schnell you can
learn it quickly I learned it as a child
xiang yu lian a zoo he say to young man
I told you that my grandfather had a
country guesthouse it had a side room
with its own ritual every Wednesday the
teachers from the surrounding area came
yes ago they were always very polite
calling each other by their formal
titles there was a definite hierarchy
yeah then they'd sit down together for
the afternoon and play chef cop shot
commute i SAT and watched and learned it
relatively quickly Island wouldn't
bother you say very quick how the number
of days or a number of weeks so I [ __ ]
took several weeks on and off on the
vios I was always very proud when
someone had to go to the toilet because
I was allowed to take his place and play
for him we played for money and I was
especially proud when I took over
someone's hand and could say mr. teacher
sir I 110 phenix for you cool father
Felix my grandfather had many decks of
cards and I inherited them when he died
I've got a whole pie
very lovely old cards that you can't
find anymore it's from some of them came
off book printing process Walden soon
gets moment nowadays it's done by offset
printing and the colors and surfaces are
different then I started collecting
cards and probably have about 60 or 70
packs from 1892 more recent times either
phone arts and wounded annoyance is she
BTW i Cardin I was Moyer outside and
you've brought along well not really two
sets of cards you brought along this set
of cards will have a look at them in a
minute but also this this is a tell us
what we've got here yeah as I enough
wendys mention one of the players that I
told you about had lost his left arm in
an accident woodman card when you play
cards you hold your hand out and a fan
you play with the other hand you than me
dun dun hunt always been 10 10 but
that's hard if you have only one arm
speed on this being at my uncle's father
so my grandfather put out this stand for
him he'd have it in front of him and
could play his cards with just his right
hand though only a mirage being cone and
you'll get your grandfather actually
made this himself each faces I don't
know for sure the great storyteller yeah
by sneaking obvious maybe he made it or
maybe he had it made by a carpenter in
any case it wasn't produced industrially
I looked underneath and there's no
industrial stamp it looks handmade seat
hunt guma but I mentioned that you are
an illustrator the I mean that must be
one reason why you are fascinated by
cards and just I mean these are very
different cards from the kind of cards
that I know when I play you know bridge
or whist at home yeah just tell good to
just take one of the cards and tell me
what we can actually see ya this is
summer shibir does he said so this for
example is a card and the heart suit and
he's dressed as a hunter he has a
hunting cap on and a gun under his arm
there are often different professions
relate like this one a minor with a
pickaxe
I'm back months by lat dear this one is
possibly a waiter because he has a
bottle or maybe he's a drinker I don't
know there's very good isn't it okay
we've got this other set here mmm very
lovely yes men lieblings this is my
favorite deck and I imagine it's also
the most valuable it comes from a
magazine called Uganda which gave its
name to the art movement called yugen
steer or art nouveau around 1900 all the
magazine subscribers got this pack as a
present i'm gu shrink a free gift so to
speak for subscribing cod is cranky disc
the cards are illustrated by important
you can steal artists it was three it
wonderful cards wonderful Cal yeah yeah
yeah and how did you get these way to do
where did they come from did you buy
them did you know I was fortunate enough
that my parents-in-law my wife's parents
subscribe to human magazine would Jesus
cotton and they just gave me the deck
when they heard that I collect cards
that's each boot cut and summer
wonderful yeah thank you for sharing
that with us before we finish I've got
one question that I want to ask you
about children's books as possibly
Germany's most popular children's books
author of children's books what is your
favorite children's book for love my own
from the other guys the other folks ya
know with you and nothing is skip the
important p let me think there's a book
by peter hacks it's called the spindle
off the air pocket and it's the book
that got me writing children's stories
in the first place I'd actually started
writing something for adults a radio
play and poems and then i read peter
hack story and I thought I want to do
that Tony's it won't stop this reverse
redic my wonderful in faith recommend
you stop going into the German that
polymer that's all we've got time for
with him but it's been a great guest a
fantastic story teller oh do come back
next week bye bye truce